you know if there was just one thing you
would have implemented in the early
stages of your recruitment career with
the hands that you have now what would
it be planning yep yeah I was yeah it
like I literally was like I'll just go
into the office and see what happens
today you have to go in with a plan you
know you've got to know what you're
doing I always say candidates for the
morning beat in the afternoon candidates
will be your BD I could go on all day
about it but I see so many people coming
into Recruitment and they go into the
office and like I don't know what I'm
doing today you've wasted a day already
if you go in and don't know what you're
doing you might as well just not go in
goodbye that's the hardest thing